on the surface bong Joon hos snowpiercer
is quite literally a linear story after
a mass extinction event leaving the
world in uninhabitable cold the last
fraction of humanity survives on an ark
like train that will travel around the
world it is supposed attorney the film
chronicles the attempt of the
impoverished members of the trains tail
section as they try to overtake the
godlike captain at the very front
Wilfred as the tail section Warriors led
militarily by Chris Evans as Curtis and
spiritually by John Hurt as Gilliam make
their way through successive
compartments of the train were treated
to a sort of live-action flowchart of
the class system in a hierarchical
Society it's quite obvious that
snowpiercer is an allegory of class
culture and how tensions innate within
it lead to resentment and eventually
revolution some have criticized the film
for being so transparent in this respect
but the genius in director bong Joon hos
art how sci-fi action film is not in the
message as such but how through the
tools and techniques of filmmaking he
conveys it for example it's
understandable symbolically why the tail
section of the Train might not have any
windows for passengers of that section
the Train is literally the world in the
whole wide just as the lower classes in
society are forced to be concerned
almost exclusively with survival living
at the whims of ideologies invented by
those of higher cultural standings show
a taste but as Curtis and his van reach
the front of the train toward the end of
the film we noticed that those sections
are also devoid of windows in sauna cars
and rave cars and drug cars the affluent
members of the upper class are just as
encouraged as their counterparts to
consider the Train as the entirety of
what there is even in the sacred engine
room where ed harris as Wilfred
maintains the life-giving machine he
created there's an almost claustrophobic
feeling a feeling of
only being able to see in the direction
of the linear trains linear path the
trainers who world dream in the whole
wide range of lzz famously said it's
much easier to imagine the end of all
life on earth then a much more modest
radical change in capitalism this
philosophy is central to snowpiercer the
first time the tail section looks
laterally out of the window their
response is as Gilliam attest these
people can't see anything outside of the
Train but death their focus is either
forward or backward and all throughout
the film we see Kurtis making choices
that force him to look in either of
these two directions filmed by joon-ho
in beautiful profile we go forward small
side note the YouTube channel every
frame a painting examined Joon hos
artistic use of the profile shot from
another of his films mother which is
great and I'll leave a link for in the
description the front and tail sections
are similar in another way in color
scheme both are muted in the back it's a
mix of greens and blues in the engine
room a kind of off-white predominates a
spoiled white symbolizing the false
redemption of curtis's revolution and
indeed as the film bears out his
revolution doesn't represent salvation
for the sufferers of the train as he
himself realizes when Wilford names him
as the successor Curtis was only
perpetuating the system he sought to
bring down like so many revolutions in
the real world Curtis and Gilliam's
Revolution was in fact an essential part
of the exploited of system joon-ho
understands this visually he's trying to
direct our attention to another part of
the train and another pair of
protagonists it's the middle section
where windows outfit every car it's the
middle section where a muted colors
explode into the full spectrum and it's
two passengers from the middle section
namgoong and his daughter Jana who
eventually make the choice to derail the
train and escape into a world all others
see as frozen and dead as Curtis fights
his way forward
namgoong is repeated leaking
with what's outside the train making
sure his daughter sees that too in this
scene he explains to her what dirt is
that he used to walk with it under his
feet zeona is a train baby which means
that she's never known any world but the
Train her father educates and protects
her from the violence that defines the
hierarchical struggle he wants her to
escape by far the most symbolically rich
scene of the film and the one I think
joon-ho is loudly signalling as the most
important by his use of a full rainbow
of color is the car in which the
middle-class excuse me the middle of the
Train children are quote-unquote
educated of course like the front and
the back the middle of the Train is
meant to represent the middle class of
something close to but not exactly akin
to contemporary capitalist society
educated enough to think for themselves
yet comfortable enough to be highly
susceptible to propaganda the middle
class is at once the most important and
the most dangerous cross section of
society and the school is the place
where the middle class is indoctrinated
into a system that will exploit them and
those less fortunate
where ideology is most powerful indeed
this is how the members of the middle
class become the tail sections faceless
oppressors all at the bidding of those
who languish in hedonism and power
earlier in the film Curtis figures out
that the blunt tools of those oppressors
their guns are devoid of bullets yet
when he gets to the school joon-ho shows
us where the invisible but real violence
in this society lies and in a great
foreshadowing of the futility of
curtis's quest the guns are hidden
underneath eggs death in false birth
here again
namgoong instruct Sione to look outside
as the children are indoctrinated into
their propaganda he gives her a true
education which eventually comes to
fruition in a true lateral escape from
their linear
a story we like Yona are all of us
trained babies born into a system that
seems as immutable as the earth in
snowpiercer bong joon-ho gives us a
poetic glimpse into how this system
works and as he shows in the film
sometimes the best historian
is the artist
you